so scaling
four areas of focus
I don't know what to do as a CEO it's
kind of like I don't really know what my
role is as a CEO until finally after a
lot of research and time I spent with
other CEOs I came with a basic formula
for myself whatever I do on the bottom
here helps my business grow like this
linear six percent twelve percent eight
percent steady per year
operations which is systems and bits Dev
hey John how you doing so tell me what
you do what kind of Technology you guys
offer okay what if we can figure out a
way to collaborate and work together
great you know what I'll call you back
let's get to get them put a meeting you
know what hey how you doing Mary what do
you do oh you can let me introduce you
to Bobby okay I'll talk to Bobby and
also you meet somebody that introduces
something like I went to a conference
one time we met all these other guys and
I met a guy named David David Fenimore
comes back and we have a negotiation
together and he's trying to get money
from me I'm like wait a minute I'm
introducing you to the biggest insurance
companies in the world that's going to
make you 40 million dollars you want me
to pay you for this software I'm not
paying you for this software very strong
negotiation he got off the call it was a
five minute call he was kind of like
what was this all about everybody Cuts
this check for me I said not this guy
you're gonna do it for me for free but
I'm not cutting you a penny to do
business with you on this you decide
think about it call me on Monday I get
off the phone I'm thinking I lost this
guy
so one of the biggest guys who has
access to two billion dollars of capital
calls him saying we're looking to invest
into an insurance agency who do you
recommend you know who he recommends me
so the guy I negotiated strong with
recommends me to this other guy so I get
on the phone with him I said what did he
tell you about me because at this point
I'm kind of like why would he ever you
refer to me he said well he told me
you're a pretty strong negotiator I said
so would why would you want he says well
if we want a CEO to invest in we want
somebody that's going to hold the fort
down and we feel good about you and let
me tell you who our people are and then
they brought me Oscar De La Hoya
Gabrielle Brenner they brought the
contact but Biz that if I don't do the
handshaking tell me your story what do
you do what do you do I don't meet that
person both are necessary both are
necessary but neither makes you explode
as a company these two this is where you
explode your business number one next
Innovative campaign
what is next Innovative campaign
the next thing you're launching in your
office
to motivate your sales people to
motivate your sales leaders to motivate
your employees to motivate your
Executives to motivate everybody and
it's the next Innovative campaign the
next thing you're launching to drive
your customers what are you going to be
driving there it's next Innovative
campaign what do you do in the month of
January to bring customers based on your
season what do you do in February March
April for the longest time in our
business June through August Seasons
we're weak and December to February
seasons were weak I made a whole launch
on June July August and December January
February because those three months I
kept everybody active it took up our
revenues
I think we're at 17 quarters in a row of
selling more insurance policies than the
quarter before 17 quarters not here
quarters in a row and it was all about
next Innovative campaign how many guys
here like the kids keep your kids
distracted who likes to give their kids
to keep their kids distracted anybody
here how many guys think distractions
are bad things anybody thinks
distractions are bad things yes of
course right I love distractions
but positive distractions
typically parents will tell you what is
the best distraction for kids
what is it best distraction for kids is
what just put your kids there and it's a
good distraction away from not doing
drugs and joining gangs what is it
Sports TV's not a good distraction
Sports they're going to sports a coach
kicks their ass they get a little bit
tougher they compete they're trying to
get in shape no I'm not going to smoke
no I'm not going to drink and they kind
of make it to the next level right
your employees your sales people your
customers they all need positive
distractions most CEOs and Founders and
sales leaders don't have enough
distractions for their leaders so they
keep losing customers they keep losing
employees because they're not positively
distracting their people believe me this
guy was the expert because I lost people
regularly my first tenure in business
then the last one this this right here
you can go all the way up to being a
president if you get good at this
anybody in this room you can go all the
way up to being a president if you're
good at this if you become good at
developing leaders you're an asset to
every industry
anybody that became a CEO of uber and
all this other guy you think the CEO's
expertise is rent you know getting a cab
and all this other stuff no
those people get hired because they
mastered leadership development
they know how to recruit people and
build them people wanted to go work with
jobs because jobs was building leaders
like oh my gosh I want to work with this
guy
they were working with Microsoft and
they're going to Bezos man I just want
to be able to work with besos because
they're building leaders the moment you
get good at that place your business
doesn't grow like this your business
grows from out of control because now
you got 10 20 generals that think speak
negotiate like you and if you're very
good you're dangerous your company
officially becomes dangerous
official becomes dangerous especially if
you're teaching the right values and
principles that's a very dangerous
company to compete with
people are frightened of going up
against the company
that the people at the top know how to
develop leaders so for you leaving this
place remember what I told you next 15
moves what your moves has got to be how
good are we here
how could am I with Biz Dev am I good at
shaking hands and going through people
and meeting people
do we constantly think about our next
Innovative campaign seasonally monthly
employee sales
how good Amaya developing leaders do I
Snap
am I good at the small one-on-one
conversations or am I preaching more do
I pull the person inside and say John
can I talk to you guys let's go for a
walk
let's go for a walk around the building
what do you want to talk about look one
thing I notice about you is you like
respect right yes what was that all
about what do you mean what was that all
about in front of your employees do you
think that was good come on man you know
you're better than that you know that
person will run through a wall for you
just lost that person's loyalty you got
to go take that person to have coffee
with them right now it's what you got to
do go and I'm not I'm gonna walk the
other way so the person doesn't think
that I told you to do this and then that
other person you know that person's mom
just passed away two weeks ago why are
you talking like this pull them aside
give them a nice book give them a nice
good goalkeeper 20 gift card say go do
something what's that all about no your
iPad dude you keep telling me you want
to get to the next level to get to the
next level you got to be better with
people okay then he leaves hey I'm so
sorry can I take you to Coffee let's go
I look you're the most loyal person I
have you know the department would be
the same without you hey I'm so sorry
about the lost your mom like I just got
this gift for you man just go on you you
know what today just leave early go
spend some time with your husband I
heard I'm so sorry I just really boom
that's leadership development those
small eight-minute conversation nine
minute walk three minute walk all of a
sudden everybody's doing that in your
organization now you're getting thicker
now you're making real money
how many stuff is just kind of going
like this to you or is it sticking is
any of this stuff making sense yes no
okay good so make continue
formulas simple you need the right story
you need the right team the right data
the right strategies then it's
predictable skill
some of you guys have the right story
you don't know how to tell it
you got to figure out a better way of
telling your real story
most people don't know how to tell the
real story most people don't have the
right team a guy was asking me a
question if you want to are you going to
send your kids to college Patrick
because you say college is a scam
how many of you guys think I'm going to
send my kids to college
how many guys say Pat's not going to
send this gift to college what do you
think
okay
if my kid absolutely doesn't want to go
to college you think I'm going to force
him my personality
absolutely not if my kid wants to go to
college you think I'm going to have him
go yes or what yes or no but you know
what I'm going to tell I'm up front I'm
gonna say son listen to me buddy look
bro
in college a 2.0 GP is the same thing as
4.0 GPA no one gives a [__]
they just want that certificate on the
wall okay but here's what you're gonna
do when you go to college you have to
befriend the richest parents kids
whoever in your class find out all their
last name and find out who their parents
are go befriend them
number two
the person that's the smartest kid
that's Tech and is a nerd very weird is
offensive sometimes befriend him
okay I'm gonna tell them exactly who to
befriend the dean go take care of the
dean
go be good to these people in the
Departments
your friend all these guys that are
placing people in companies
because they can get you on the lawyer
they can get you in Goldman Sachs they
can get you on do all this stuff buddy
that's what you're going to be doing
makes sense yes and then after college
get your degree so put it on the wall
you want to go be a lawyer too do you
want to get your MBA go for it you want
to go be adopted whatever
but make sure you build the right team
around you because this right here
something very few people talk about
very few people tell them let me tell
you the right team
all day
the right team is game over any industry
put the right team together game over
all I'm teaching people is build the
right team so right story write team
write data you study write strategies
then you're predictably scale
[Music]